a wedding celebration turned at Mass
funeral a day after a fire ripped
through the venue
like people went to have fun but it
became the opposite it was turned upside
down and got sadness instead of
happiness I mean it is a very big
tragedy honestly the atmosphere is
unbearable and we are very sad
[Music]
family is now decimated
there are families who lost four others
lost five but thanks to God we are
blessed because my son has three sons he
lost one and still has two
searching for their loved ones
at the wedding party
he fell over her head I was with them we
were sitting next to the kitchen and
when the door was opened we got out
through there or else we wouldn't have
been able to escape
neighbors who try to help now traumatize
too
we heard ambulances and the cars since
our Monastery is close to the hall we
came out to check what happened bodies
were being taken out young people were
flooding to the hall to get out as many
people as they could
authorities say fireworks started the
fire that tore through the packed Hall
flammable materials used in the
construction of buildings like this one
helped the fire to spread rapidly some
of the bodies of dead are so badly
charred that it is difficult for
emergency teams to identify them
officials say an investigation is
underway and a number of people have
been arrested
is ongoing
going for the reason of the fire was the
setting off of fires inside the hole the
use of fireworks in an unusual way and
as you know fireworks are not permitted
outside of the hall let alone using them
inside
deadly fires are frequent in Iraq but
people here say until serious action is
taken to ensure safety and
accountability
tragedies like this will happen again
[Music]
Iraq
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera